I reject the concept of being a born
entrepreneur the Natural Born
entrepreneurs are just typically people
who got reinforced for doing
entrepreneurial type behaviors earlier I
was a very security driven person for
most of my life I just had jobs and then
I went to college and then I got a white
collar job that had Prestige around it
the most terrifying thing in the entire
world for me was quitting that job it
took me six months to quit a job and I
was 22 or 23 and I had 50 000 saved up
and I was petrified but it was because
I'd never been rewarded for that so it
was such a huge change in behavior for
me because I've been rewarded over and
over and over again for doing what I was
told so I think in some ways the guys
who did fail out of school and things
like that and then became entrepreneurs
it's like well they never got rewarded
for following the directions I had been
rewarded for following the directions
which is why it was so much harder for
me to quit